you remember those headlines about how
Trump was going to irreversibly divide
and destroy the GOP oh there they are
well it turns out that the president may
well be on his way to healing those
divisions oh sure there's still some
policy disagreements but on the big
issues the unity of spirit and purpose
is kind of remarkable and it needs to be
acknowledged you think about where the
GOP was and let's say 2008 or 2012 early
2016 and now think about where it is
today once upon a time the Republican
leadership had little regard and minimal
respect for the real estate mogul who
crashed their party
just remember the kinds of things the
GOP leadership had said about Trump of
course I've been in a lot of work
and I think excessive expectations about
how quickly things happen in the
democratic process claiming a person
can't do the job because of their race
is sort of like the textbook definition
of a racist comment I think that should
be absolutely disavowed it's absolutely
unacceptable so the narrative from the
GOP establishment was that Donald Trump
was a divisive figure who was an engaged
in policy he didn't understand the ways
of Washington oh really I was told by
multiple congressional sources that the
President worked the phone's tirelessly
to get this tax bill tax bill done for
the American people
he has been intimately involved in
remaking trade policy to benefit the
American worker as well and of course
his efforts to revive the economy seem
to be paying off home sales hit their
highest level in ten years
stock market breaking all kind of
records and of course he delivered that
tax break everybody loves a winner and
now the president has turned some of his
fiercest critics into allies listen to
him now a year of extraordinary
accomplishment for the Trump
administration something this big
something this generational something
this profound could not have been done
without exquisite presidential
leadership I've never ever in my life
used the word fake news until today I
actually understand what it is the
president has been dealing with not only
is that a stunning reversal of their
view of the president style but he's
converted them or at least cowed them on
a number of key issues so for instance
like when's the last time a prominent
Republican really complained about
Trump's efforts to renegotiate NAFTA or
challenged China in case you didn't
notice Mitch McConnell now sounds like
Jeff Sessions on immigration defying
expectations
again the president has pulled his party
toward the conservative populist
movement that swept him into office his
detractors are now realizing that the
Trump way is the only way forward it's
finally finally dawned on them
there's simply no constituency for the
GOP of open borders endless wars and
those lopsided trade deals you want to
know who the dividers are today in the
GOP I'll tell you who they are you see
him they're the bushes Jeff Flake Mitt
Romney and other bitter globalists whose
time is frankly come and gone like the
ghosts of Christmas past they're
wandering the halls making noises but no
one's listening this is a trumpian party
now and that's the angle